commissaire Thomas boudo bonsoir merci
d'être venu donc sur ce plateau
lorsqu'on pense police scientifique on
pense forcément à différentes séries
télé aujourd'hui c'est devenu très à la
mode à la police scientifique est-ce
qu'on est près de la réalité ou est-ce
que c'est plutôt du domaine du fantasme
on va juste donner la parole aux 5
continents et vous pourrez ensuite nous
répondre
non alors je pense que c'est un peu trop
rapide
on voit parce que il y a des reportages
qui sont faits pour tout ce qui est
analyse ADN et choses comme ça qui
prennent du temps apparemment en France
et qui se font en cinq minutes aux
États-Unis donc tout est un peu accéléré
il y a plus de technologie aussi je
pense non ça n'a rien à voir ça rien à
voir pourquoi
la base ça va ça va tellement vite quoi
une empreinte de jour dans la journée de
l'an alors qu'ici en France ça peut
prendre un mois de moi ça serait trop
beau quoi en fait je pense pas qu'on
puisse
faire des enquêtes et puis les les
déficelés avec des moyens on a
certainement certes on a des moyens mais
pas autant là c'est comme de la fiction
ça reste quand même dans le domaine de
la fiction plutôt
fiction ou réalité écoutez moi je ne
dirais pas que c'est de la fiction
puisque précisément mon service qui est
en charge la prise technique et
scientifique sur le département des
Yvelines à des moyens très importants
donc effectivement quand on regarde les
séries télévisées on peut se dire qu'on
est peut-être des fois un peu éloigné
pour autant il est clair qu'en matière
de d'empreinte génétique et d'empreintes
papillaire on arrive à avoir des
résultats qui n'ont pas nous faire
rougir par rapport à ce qui se fait
autrement et quand vous voyez justement
toutes ces différentes séries télé juste
pour conclure sur ça parce que c'est
vrai qu'effectivement ça intéresse
beaucoup les gens qui regardent ces
séries quand on voit les et les
audiences réalisées comment vous
expliquer tout cet intérêt autour de
toutes ces méthodes scientifiques
appliquées dans la police parce
qu'effectivement c'est entre le
scientifique et puis aussi l'enquête de
police donc forcément ça passionne les
gens mais je rappellerai quand même que
la politique est scientifique sans aller
dans les origines remonte quand même au
XIXe siècle et on a quand même des gens
c'est des Français à la base Bertillon
notamment où Edmond Locar à Lyon qui
sont les précurseurs de de la politique
scientifique telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui la police technique
scientifique a toujours eu une place
véritablement importante pour résoudre
les différentes affaires en France tout
à fait sauf que effectivement
aujourd'hui on arrive à un degré les
dernières années sont des années très
importantes puisqu'effectivement on
arrive maintenant matière d'ADN à avoir
des résultats encore plus spectaculaires
qu'avant grâce à notamment des
techniques des techniques pardon qui
nous viennent notamment du Canada ou
d'ailleurs depuis le milieu des années
90 à peu près ou véritablement dans le
département des Yvelines cette
Polytechnique scientifique a un rôle
prépondérant tout à fait donc les
fichiers on a deux fichiers le fichier
des empreintes digitales qui date de 87
donc c'est quand même pas récent et le
fichier des empreintes génétiques qui
date de 98 suite à diverses affaires
qu'on défraie la chronique en matière
sexuelle alors si on s'intéresse non pas
aux affaires sexuelles mais au
cambriolages qui sont l'eau un petit peu
de tous les jours pour la police aussi
plus 6% dans le département des Yvelines
en 2012 ça veut dire forcément beaucoup
plus de travail pour pour vos services
tout à fait puisque le but c'est ce
qu'on tient à faire c'est de d'être sur
l'ensemble des cambriolages donc à
chaque cambriolage quelque soit la
nature du cambriolage quel que soit la
nature
pas du tout donc pour le cambriolage
pour lequel on est saisi mais effectifs
se déplacent sur les lieux et tente de
prendre des empreintes ou de l'ADN et de
faire des constatations qui puissent
permettre effectivement à l'issue
d'identifier d'interpeller
éventuellement un individu qui serait
sur une des bases des fichiers dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure justement
est-ce que tout ça est très efficace
lorsque vous intervenez ensuite le
succès derrière et quasiment assuré le
succès n'est pas assuré je à 100% bien
sûr pour autant comme a pu le dire mon
directeur dans votre reportage sur les
affaires de cambriolages et les idées
50% sont attribués à la pts à la police
technique et scientifique donc c'est pas
rien même si effectivement on espère
augmenter ce chiffre à 60 70 %. et ce
reportage que vous avez mentionné qui
est déjà diffusé sur notre antenne je
vous propose de le retrouver à présent
c'est la semaine dernière que vous avez
ouvert vos services à la presse pour
présenter justement vos différentes
techniques d'intervention reportage de
Valérie Auribeau
son propre télé pour la seconde année
consécutive le nombre de cambriolages a
augmenté plus 6% en 2012 dans les
Yvelines certes le chiffre de plus de
18% de hausse de 2011 à BC mais la
progression demeure pour répondre à ces
infractions l'accent est mis sur la
police technique et scientifique
aujourd'hui nous résolvons dans ce
département comme au niveau national une
dizaine de pour cent des cambriolages
donc
ce taux
mérite d'être amélioré
68 policiers polyvalents transformer
sont désormais dévolus en partie à cette
tâche en amont ces policiers signalisent
les individus mise en cause dans un fait
de délinquance les empreintes sont
archivées dans les fichiers de la police
sur les lieux des infractions les agents
prélèvent les traces éventuelles
laissées par les auteurs afin de
comparer ses indices avec les données
archivées traces ADN papillaire
empreinte sur place rien n'est négligé
la première mission c'est la protection
des tracés indices la deuxième étape
très importante c'est la fixation des
lieux au moyen de photographie les
indices biologiques récoltés sont
protégés afin d'être ultérieurement
examinés pour 100 hauteur identifiées 50
leçons grâce à la police technique et
scientifique 35 grâce à un témoin 15%
grâce à l'enquête rappelons que la
prévention reste la meilleure des
protections fermées porte et fenêtres en
partant si possible faire installer une
alarme et prévenir le comm issariat ou
la gendarmerie en cas de départ prolongé
on l'a entendu dans ce reportage
peut-être la phrase clé c'est rien n'est
négligé par vos services ça veut dire
qu'une intervention est très longue elle
prend du temps effectivement pour que on
puisse en fonction des pièces qui ont pu
être visitées dans la dans l'appartement
dans la maison se donner le maximum de
chances de retrouver des traces pour
autant combien même on a des traces on
ne veut pas dire forcément que son les
traces des auteurs du cambriolage ça
peut être aussi comme on a pu
l'expliquer dans le portage aussi des
familiers c'est à dire des gens qui
habitent la maison ou des amis et donc
après le travail pour la police
technique et scientifique c'est
effectivement de différencier
les traces qui appartiennent au
familiers de celles éventuellement qu'à
appartiennent aux auteurs on parlait
tout à l'heure de la des techniques de
la modernisation permanente
véritablement elle est permanente cette
modernisation chaque année de nouvelles
technologies arrivent ça veut dire que
vos effectifs doivent aussi
régulièrement se mettre à jour tout à
fait dans le domaine de la police
technique et scientifique on parle
effectivement là de l'ADN on parle aussi
des traces papillières mais il y a pas
que ça aussi il y a aussi la
cybercriminalité donc qui est la
recherche notamment dans les ordinateurs
dans dans les moyens de communication
moderne que sont le téléphone le GPS et
ça peut permettre aussi de résoudre des
affaires de cambriolage également donc
oui on est on essaie d'être le plus en
point de possibles et de devancer
ton faire ce peu le cambrioleurs les
cambrioleurs qui aujourd'hui sont bien
informés de vos différentes techniques
parce que vous ouvrez vos services par
exemple on l'a vu aussi avec toutes ces
séries télé qui se multiplient c'est
peut-être une difficulté supplémentaire
pour vous aussi c'est de trouver des
moyens de contourner en tout cas pas
divulguer toutes les informations dont
vous pouvez disposer la campagne de
communication à l'initiative de notre
directeur à une double vertu en fait la
première des vertus effectivement elle
est préventive parce que au-delà de
monter nos techniques
préventivement déjà au niveau des
victimes parce que on a parlé d'appel 17
qui est très important mais il y a pas
que l'appel 17 il y a aussi le fait de
dire parce que la plupart des
cambriolages se passent en journée et
sur des tranches horaires vraiment très
courtes c'est-à-dire c'est la la femme
ou l'homme qui part accompagner ses
enfants qui part 10 minutes et qui ne
ferme pas sa porte à clé qui me fait les
volets qui va chercher du pain voilà
tout à fait et la dissuasion
effectivement de montrer aussi au
cambrioleur que effectivement nous
sommes aussi réactifs vis-à-vis de ces
nouveaux phénomènes il y a des moments
où sur des interventions vous vous dites
voilà là on a touché le maximum on n'a
pas les techniques suffisantes pour nous
permettre d'avancer plus il faudra
encore développer autre chose ça arrive
quelquefois toujours parce qu'on essaie
toujours de d'être de plus en plus
performant effectivement bon le matériel
arrive petit à petit dans les services
mais oui c'est une question récurrente
puisque effectivement comme vous le
savez les délinquants aussi ont des
techniques et souvent on change
régulièrement pour éviter qu'on les
qu'on les pista lorsque la police
technique scientifique intervient c'est
un coût important parce que vous disiez
vous intervenez sur les cambriolages dès
que vous êtes sollicité vous intervenez
mais derrière il y a le coût également
oui ben le coup en fait c'est pas
forcément chiffrable vraiment puisque
effectivement à chaque fois qu'on se
déplace on appelle ça vous avez vu sur
le reportage des écouvillons donc ça
c'est des choses qui valent quelques
centimes d'euros mais effectivement
multipliés au nombre de déplacements et
de découvrir ça peut représenter une
somme mais qui de toute façon est tout à
fait prise en compte et en considération
dans dans la gestion d'un service comme
le mien petit rappel combien de
personnes dans votre service justement
alors oui dans votre portail vous
parliez de de 68 polyvalents en fait non
c'est pas vraiment ça on a 68
spécialistes
dans mon service et vous avez puisqu'il
y a 2.200 policiers dans le département
des Yvelines vous avez 280 personnes
qu'on appelle polyvalent qui
effectivement tous les jours peuvent
vrais dans leur quotidien des techniques
tout à fait on fait une formation d'une
semaine sur sur cette thématique là
j'aurais juste pour conclure qu'on
s'arrête sur l'ouverture récente dans
laboratoire d'analyses physico-chimiques
c'est l'une des dernières innovations
dernière nouveauté de cette
Polytechnique et scientifique dans le
département des Yvelines tout à fait
c'est à Poissy c'est à Poissy on en a
d'autres également aussi sur Rambouillet
et menthe mais le dernier en date et le
plus performant le plus actuel
effectivement de Poissy ou effectivement
on peut à l'aide de la nitrine notamment
et d'autres procédés physiochimiques
faire des relevés sur n'importe quel
support merci d'être venu nous présenter
vos services commissaires Thomas Budo
donc cette présentation de la police
scientifique des Yvelines techniques
scientifique des Yvelines qui est très
sollicité on disait avec cette hausse
des cambriolages mais la meilleure des
préventions bien évidemment pour éviter
le cambriolage c'est de bien fermer la
porte déjà quand on va déposer les
enfants faire le 17 et de faire le 17
ensuite merci d'être venu nous présenter
vos services le 7 8 sport nouvelle
édition à suivre dans moins de 4 minutes
juste après ce reportage consacré à la
maison médicale de garde de Montigny
elle fête ses 10 ans nous vous l'avions
présenté il y a quelques semaines mais
nous avons voulu savoir quel était sa
fréquentation je vous rappelle le
principe les soirs et les week-ends
après un appel au centre 15 vous pouvez
être dirigé vers ce groupement de
médecins installer donc à Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines ils sont une dizaine sur
place à se relayer Catherine zulato
Patrick Jacques de dix Mull les a
rencontré
dimanche il est 16h le docteur Villier
vient démarrer sa garde à la maison
médicale de Montigny
il est accueilli par sa consœur qui elle
termine la garde du matin tous
s'enchaînent le docteur Villié doit
appeler le 15 pour prévenir de sa
présence
médicale de Guyancourt Montigny voisin
et la gare des parties pour quatre
heures pendant la première tranche
horaire le médecin de garde a reçu 14
passions
il s'agit de la médecine générale
pressée il s'agit pas de l'urgence
vitale il s'agit pas non plus de faire
le certificat médical sportif il s'agit
d'assurer la permanence des soins pour
un certain nombre de pathologies qui
n'ont-ils les préférable qu'elle
n'attendent pas ou alors pour des
situations pour lesquelles il les
besoins d'un avis médical pour savoir
s'il faut aller à l'hôpital par exemple
la maison médicale de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux existe depuis 10
ans tout le monde peut y accéder après
une régulation assurée par le 15 qui
donne le code d'accès le secteur couvre
notamment Montigny Guyancourt et voisins
l'idée est né d'une volonté de médecins
de se regrouper pour assurer une
permanence de soins en dehors des
horaires d'ouverture des cabinets
médicaux classiques c'est-à-dire le soir
le week-end et les jours fériés 45
médecins adhèrent à ce réseau l'idée
c'est qu'il y a plein de gens qui vont à
l'hôpital aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas y
aller alors ils y vont pour des
pathologies bénignes ils y vont souvent
parce que il y a une dispense d'avance
de frais ça c'est clair ils y vont parce
que ils pensent qu'on va leur faire
plein d'examens comme c'est l'hôpital on
fait plein d'examens ça coûte une
fortune ce sont souvent des choses qui
ne sont pas nécessaires
en 2012 la maison médicale a traité plus
de 4000 actes pour seulement une
quarantaine d'hospitalisation Philippe
Velay souffre de fièvre et de
courbatures il est venu accompagner de
son épouse
je me suis dit que ça nécessitait pas
vraiment les urgences mais qu'il fallait
qu'il voit un médecin donc du coup quand
j'ai regardé sur internet et que j'ai vu
que c'était à côté j'ai été rassuré
l'hôpital avec le temps d'attente avec
le trajet surtout si on a un enfant
malade et c'est vraiment pratique la
maison médicalisée c'est sécurisée c'est
à deux pas de chez nous on habite à
Montigny la formule fait donc ses
preuves elles permettent désengorger les
urgences médicales et le ministère de la
Santé verrait d'un bon œil que ce
système de maison médicale soit étendu à
d'autres communes alentours jusqu'à
Versailles et cela les médecins n'y sont
pas favorables plus nous allons être
nombreux plus la logistique va être
lourde plus ça va être compliqué alors
que notre projet initial et bien c'est
de nous entraider entre nous et avec
tout un système de confiance de choix
entre nous qui fait que on est
parfaitement tranquille c'est un
collègue amis qui qui prend la garde là
ça devient quelque chose de beaucoup
plus difficile à gérer avec l'ouverture
d'un autre cabinet à l'étage des listes
de garde beaucoup plus compliquées à
faire
la consultation de journée s'établit à
49,50 €, 65 euros 50 pour le soir les
médecins perçoivent une indemnité
forfaitaire versé à chaque garde à
laquelle s'ajoutent leurs honoraires
actuellement dans les Yvelines il existe
trois maisons médicales fixes et une
maison médicale dite mobile sur le
secteur de Rambouillet